so as Ned said my name is Ned Batchelder
I'm Ned bat on most social media and
there is a bitly short link there at the
bottom of the slide that links to this
talk online if you want to follow along
with the slides and those two short
things will be at the bottom of most of
the slides too so I've been writing
software for a long time and one of the
things that interests me about writing
software is that there are two mindsets
that inform the process of writing
software the first is computer science
which is really a branch of mathematics
and so it's very theoretical you do
proofs you think about very abstract
concepts the other mindset that informs
writing software is software engineering
which is very pragmatic and is basically
concerned only with whether you are
writing software that works how can we
write software that works and there is
some crossover lots of computer science
underpins software engineering but we
don't think about it every day but
there's a few topics that do crossover
into the everyday of software
engineering and in particular I'm
interested in people who are working in
software engineering who don't have
formal computer science backgrounds and
maybe feel a little bit insecure about
that and one of the things that they
seem to feel keeps them from sitting at
the grown-ups table is this thing called
Big O a Big O is really a simple thing
and I've made a rhyme here to help you
remember what it is it's about how your
code slows as your data grows and an
English major friend of mine pointed out
that the rhyme is on the O sound like
Big O and I didn't intend that at all
but that's cool so the question is how
does your code slow down as the data
gets larger and larger and this is not
the same as the running time of any
particular run of your code we're not
trying to measure the time in seconds
we're not trying to figure out exactly
how many of them you can do in one
transaction we're talking about the
trend over time over many runs of your
code how does it slow down as the data
gets larger and larger and larger and
one very pragmatic way to think about
this is let's say you have a chunk of
code you give it a certain amount of
data it takes a certain amount of time
how much longer will it take to work on
ten times as much data if I give it ten
times as much data how much longer does
it take and you might think intuitively
well it'll take ten times as long
obvious
but that turns out not to be true some
code will take ten times as long some
code will take twice as long some code
will take a hundred times as long and
some code won't take any longer at all
and Big O is all about characterizing
that growth of the time of the code as
the code as the data grows how the code
slows as the data grows and computer
science people approach this topic in a
very very mathematical way but software
engineers approach it in a very very
pragmatic way and I'm trying to I'm
going to explain the pragmatic approach
it doesn't have to be done in a Matthew
way it can be done in a pragmatic way so
let's get some terminology out of the
way this is called the Big O notation
and the way it's written is a capital o
and a parenthesis and then a bunch of
stuff with an N in it and a closed
parenthesis okay I told you it was
simple the N is meant to stand in for
how much data you have and the O stands
for order of and the idea is that we're
talking about the running time of your
code grows on the same order of some
mathematical expression of n the key
thing here is although it looks like a
function call there's a name and then
parenthesis with stuff inside it's not a
function call it's just a notation and
there's probably a massy reason why it
looks like a function call but it
doesn't matter just know that it's not a
function call it's just a way of
labeling a piece of code as having a
certain growth pattern
so let's take a real-world example let's
say we have to count the number of beans
and jars right we've got this guy in the
left he opens up the jars he starts
pulling out beans one by one right we
can see here n is the number of beans
right if we give this guy a jar with ten
times as many beans it's going to take
him ten times as long
obviously I mean he's sweating this is
what's known as oh of n meaning that the
time it takes to complete the task grows
in the same way that n grows it's on the
order of n if n doubles the time doubles
if n is ten times more the time is ten
times more and you might think well
there's no other way to approach this
task but there is of course you get
beans jars that have labels on them that
tell you how many beans are in them
right this guy on the right has a much
easier job you can see how much happier
he is about it because it doesn't matter
how large a jar you give this guy on the
right it's going to take the same amount
of time for him to tell you how many
beans are in the jar this is what's
known as oh of one which is kind of a
weird mathematicians way of saying that
n isn't involved at all no matter what
happens to n the running time remains
the same Oh of n is is slower in the
long run than oh of one and this is a
silly silly real-world example but for
instance when you do for X in my list
you have an O of n operation because you
have to look at every element in the
list every bean in the jar when you do
Len of my list you don't have to look at
the elements list at all
turns out Python lists are kind of like
those jars on the right the length of
the list is written on the label on the
outside of the list and so no matter how
long the list is getting the length of
the list is a constant time operation by
the way these drawings were drawn by my
son who is in art school one thing you
might not have noticed if you look at
their eyebrows they're shaped like beans
that's that's art school for you
all right another real-world example
let's say I tell you I'm going to give
you a book and I want you to find a
certain word in the book like horse
right if I hand you a novel
you're gonna start reading until maybe
you find the word horse right this is
sounds like an O of n operation again
right because if I give you a novel
that's twice as long it might take you
twice as long until you encounter the
word horse well let's say I give you a
different book I give you an
encyclopedia now you open the
encyclopedia to the middle if the word
you're looking for is earlier than that
then you do another divide and conquer
step until you find the word horse if I
now if I give you an encyclopedia that's
twice as large it's not going to take
you twice as long there's just one more
divide and conquer step to find it
that's what's called a log of n which is
a fancy mathematicians way of saying
that so these are both real-world
examples of the kinds of tasks that sort
of sound similar when you first hear
them but how you organize the data and
therefore what algorithm you can use on
the data really affects how the length
of time it takes you to do the task
changes as the size of the data changes
right that's what we're talking about is
how your code slows as your data grows
let's get some other terms out of the
way because I'm going to be speaking
here and I might throw out some words
that are a little bit different than
earlier when we say o of one we might
tell it call it constant time I might
say that the labeled bean jars are a
constant time algorithm because the time
remains the same no matter what o if n
is often called a linear operation
because if you look at it mathematically
if there's a linear relationship between
the size of the data and the running
time o of N squared is the thing we
haven't seen yet but we will that's the
case where you wouldn't you give it ten
times more data it takes a hundred times
as long to run and that's called
quadratic because now you've got a
quadratic equation involved if you don't
remember where the quadratic equation is
it doesn't matter it's just a word that
means N squared and some other words for
Big O it's sometimes called complexity
or time complexity or algorithmic
complexity or if you want to sound
really fancy you can call it asymptotic
complexity it's all the same thing
right one of the underlying themes of
this talk is that this just this topic
of big
patien is littered with mathematical
detritus that doesn't really matter to
the key concept and don't let that stuff
throw you that's just chaff being thrown
at you by mathematicians you don't have
to let it throw you off the path so how
do you actually determine the Big O of a
piece of code the first step is you
figure out what code you're talking
about and that sounds kind of silly but
in a large system there's you might be
looking at one function and that might
be the important thing but it really
might actually be important to consider
all the callers of the function or maybe
you're looking at too large a chunk of
code you need to think about a small
piece if you're going to describe a huge
piece of code be very clear about what
piece of code you're talking about
and then when you look at that code you
should figure out what n is and I don't
mean like whether it's a hundred or a
thousand I mean what is it measuring so
if you're you have some code that's
iterating over all the records in a
database than n is how many records in
the database and our being example it
was how many beans in the jar if you're
doing a string search it might be the
length of this string
and then here's where the real work
comes in you're going to think about
that code running and you're going to
figure out how many steps there are in
the code in a typical run let me tell
you what I mean by typical first there's
two meanings of typical one is what kind
of data is it going to get in the real
world there's sort of real-world data
that kind of is what you kind of can
expect and then there's worst case data
right
a string of 40,000 spaces is not typical
data typical data is you know last names
it's mostly ASCII it it's about most to
15 characters long that kind of thing so
you can think about what's your typical
data and then another meaning of a
typical run is that over many runs of
your algorithm there's a certain number
of times the loop might run or a certain
length of string it might get so you
kind of think about the design center of
your code and you imagine running that
code through that design Center and you
count the steps and what I mean by steps
is very vague and in a way a lot of this
topic is very vague there are no units
and anything we're talking about and the
number of steps it kind of doesn't
matter what you count as a step and it
kind of doesn't matter that some steps
my
actually take longer than others because
really what you're thinking about is if
I'm doing any quills 10 I'll have this
many steps now how many for N equals 100
and so that exactly what steps there are
doesn't matter as much as how does that
count grow and I'll show you some
examples so you'll get a sense of it so
you count the steps in a typical run and
since we put in N at the top and not 10
exactly the number of steps is going to
be an expression in N you might end up
with well it's 3 n plus 47 steps
something like that and then what you do
is you keep only the most significant
part of that expression so you keep only
the highest coefficient piece and then
you throw away the coefficients so if
you had 47 n squared plus 53 n plus 101
that's N squared you throw away all the
lower order components and the exponent
coefficients and the reason is that as n
gets larger and larger and larger the
lower order components matter less and
less right 3 n plus 1 the 1 is really
important when n is 1 but when n is a
billion who cares about the 1 right
we're trying to get to that long-term
trend as the data gets very very large
and if it's 3 n that doubles when n
doubles just the way n doubles when n
doubles so the 3 is irrelevant 2 so you
get rid of the lower order components
and get rid of the coefficients and
what's left is your Big O notation now
let's look at some examples true fact I
wrote this code in November and it
didn't occur to me until I was lying in
bed this morning that this code is about
moms and it's Mother's Day
so here's an example of some code what
we're gonna do is we're gonna have a
data structure called moms which is a
list of tuples and the tuples are people
and their mothers right and then we're
gonna write a function called find mom
and find mom is gonna take that list of
moms in the name of a child and it's
gonna find the child's mom okay now if
you think about searching through this
list in a typical run in some runs we'll
find it in the first entry and some runs
we'll find it in last entry so on
average in a typical case we'll find it
about n over two times we're gonna look
through half the list so if we come down
to this line this loop is going to run n
over two times and I'm gonna say that
there are three steps in this loop we
have to get the tuple out of the list
and then we have to assign the child the
child name and we have to assign the mom
to mom named so there's three steps
which means that this line is going to
contribute three times and over two
steps to our counts this comparison
we're gonna do n over two times and
there's only one step so that gives us
another n over two and then this line is
only gonna happen once because it's the
end of the function so that's gonna give
us one more step and so what our total
is going to be 3n over 2 plus n over 2
plus 1 which simplifies down to 2n plus
1 I said that we get rid of the lower
order components which is the one we get
rid of the coefficient which is 2 this
is an O n function alright so we've just
determined that the algorithmic the
sorry the asymptotic complexity of find
mom is o of n and the way people say
that in the real world in a cubicle is
find mom is o of n or find mom is linear
find mom is o of n ok and so you saw
when we were going through the steps we
didn't really care which steps were
expensive which weren't we only wanted
to know is the relationship between the
N and the number of steps and when n
changes the number of steps is going to
change and that's what we're looking for
and notice we have no idea whether this
is fast or slow right we don't know
whether this function is going to take a
minute or a millisecond all we know is
that if we give it 10 times more data
it's probably going to take 10 times as
long let's look at another example also
about moms the same same data structure
the same mom's data structure but now
what we're gonna do is we're going to
write a function which tells us in that
data structure and how many grandmothers
are there that is how many people how
many people are mentioned both as a mom
and as a child in our list right and so
now we're gonna go all the way through
to the end of the list and I mentioned
that n over 2 before but remember we're
throwing away coefficients so in a way
the 1/2 never mattered and as you work
through this more you'll sort of get a
sense of what you can not collect in the
first place because you're gonna throw
it away anyway
so for instance this line is gonna run n
times right and notice I didn't write 3
times n here because like I said we're
throwing away coefficients this is an
event we're gonna run this line n times
now this line is going to run n times
also
but it's calling a function find mom
which we just determined was an O of n
operation in and of itself and you call
it once it's o of n and we're going to
call it n times that's going to give us
N squared and we can continue continue
on and say this is n but remember we're
gonna throw away the lower order
components we already found an N squared
it's kind of uninteresting to keep
finding the ends right but we're finding
a bunch of ends we're gonna end up with
N squared plus some number of n plus 1
which is o of N squared right so find
how many grandmother's is a quadratic
function it's o of N squared
now the idea
of course is of1 right constant time you
can do the same amount you can work on
any amount of data and not take it how
to take any longer and it seems kind of
impossible like how could that be but
remember we saw a Len of my list is o of
one because no matter how long the list
is the length is written on the outside
we can just pick it up that's kind of
boring really interesting is the looking
up a key in a dictionary is o of one no
matter how many keys are in a dictionary
it's this takes about at the same amount
of time to look up a key as in a
one-element dictionary and in the
million element dictionary which is why
dictionaries are heavily optimized and
engineered and underpin every name
lookup in Python because they're fast
and we'll get back to why it is but very
quickly it's because there's a thing
called a hash function which turns a key
into a number and in typical data the
numbers are all different and so you can
very quickly use that number to find the
place in the dictionary where the value
is now no discussion of Oh Big O
notation to be complete without showing
you the graph along the bottom we have
that flat green line labeled one of the
the x-axis is data so data grows to the
right and then the time grows going up
so the big flat line at the bottom is o
of one that looks great log n was
looking through the encyclopedia the
linear line going diagonally is o of n
and the big red one N squared just
assumes literally off the chart right so
the unscared is one of those bad things
you try to avoid because it really grows
really fast when things get big now when
we looked at our code we have to
understand what functions were calling
and how what kind of complexities
they're adding into our total function
this is a chart of the typical
operational complexities of Lists dicts
and sets in Python
by the way when people say dictionaries
are oh of one that sentence doesn't make
any sense and nouns like dictionary
can't have an algorithmic complexity
operations have an algorithmic
complexity so what you're supposed to
say is that looking up a key in a
dictionary is of1 now you'll notice that
a lot of these are kind of the same
appending to a list is o of one adding a
key in the dictionary is o of one adding
a value in a set is ov one
a big difference is looking up a value
in a list is o of n so if you're going
to search for a value in a list it's
gonna have to look at every element in
the list it's going to be that left
bean-counting guy with the sweat coming
off of his forehead but looking up a key
in a dictionary or a value in a set is o
of 1 which is why they're really really
valued so pro tip right off the bat if
you've got a program that's going to
slow look to see you if you're looking
up a value in a list and replace it with
look up an asset but there are trade
offs so when I say replace the list look
up with asset lookup you've got to keep
your eye on the big picture and this is
where understanding what piece of code
you care about matters so I said replace
a list look up with asset lookup let's
say we have some code like this where
we're gonna make a list we make a list
and then we try to find the thing in the
list and that line is o of n right we
just saw that on the table of Python
complexities so you might think well I
know what I'll do I'll make a set
instead and then I can look it up in a
set that's good if you can do that
that's good so you don't make the list
in the first place you make a set bad is
you go ahead and you make a list anyway
and then you convert it to a set and
then you do the lookup in a set right so
now that last line is great it's o of 1
which you've added a line before it
turning the list into a set which itself
is o of n like literally you've actually
slowed down your program by a tiny
amount you still have the O of n
operation of converting the list into a
set so it's very easy once you get into
this algorithmic complexity stuff to get
sort of focused on the little things and
lose sight of the big picture right this
would be a bad trade off a good trade
off would be even if you're making a
list if you can convert it into a set
once and then do many lookups so if
you're gonna do many lookups in your
list then it makes sense to turn it into
a set once and then you have you have
one o of N and then many o of 1 and your
program will go faster so you always
have to keep in mind what the real
usages of your code and where the time
is being spent about where you're gonna
sort of work on reducing the algorithmic
complexity and whether it's worth it now
this is don't read this code it to code
doesn't matter this is a real example of
code that got me started down this path
this was from a project last
the code on the left is shorter and has
fewer data structures and fewer
functions and in fact fewer loops but
it's slower than the code on the right
and the reason is that if we label
things as o of N and O of 1 the code on
the Left has an O of n operation there
because it's looking up a value in the
list the code on the right only has o of
1 operations so the code on the right
even though it's longer and has more
functions and more data structures and
more loops is o of 1 where the one on
the right is o of n and in fact I was
using it to draw drawings like this
these functions work over an entire list
of points and if you go up a level in
the code you'll see actually that that
function is called once for each point
in the list of points so the O of n on
our slow side was turning into a Bo of N
squared and so the slow code was taking
20 seconds the fast code was taking a
half a second on only 2,000 points right
I say I've been giving examples like o
when n gets to a billion and got to
2,000 here and made a huge difference in
my running time because N squared is
really worse than n with n of 2,000 n
squared is 4 million operations and o of
n is 2,000 operations and that's a big
difference so it really does pay off
sometimes to reduce the algorithmic
complexity of your code to reduce the
running time now we've been talking
about oh of 1 and O of N and over N
squared there's more possibilities so
there's more possibilities of kinds of
complexities you might encounter in the
real world of course there's o of n
cubed and then forth right if we called
how many grandmother's wants for every
child for some reason we'd have an N
cubed operation if I use that point
algorithm once again for every point I'd
have gone back up on an end level I'd to
know the coefficient to my n you can
also have worse things like o of 2 to
the N if you have n boolean choices and
you try all the combinations of them
you've got 2 to the N if you have n
things and you try to try all
permutations of those end things you'll
have n factorial so as bad as N squared
is there's sort of no upper limit to how
horrible your code can get so think
about how your loops are working where
how much data you're working on and keep
an eye on where those
CLEC students are getting really really
big the other kinds of possibilities is
there could be more dimensions so we've
been talking about doing algorithmic
analysis where we have one variable n
but you could have others right if I'm
telling you that I've got a string
search algorithm over some number of
strings I should maybe also have to
consider the length of those strings
typically they're fairly short but if
you're doing you know biopython or
something you have DNA samples that are
millions of characters long and then
suddenly the lengths of the strings
matter - for example when I was doing
that point drawing code there was a line
intersection algorithm that I found
whose stated complexity was n plus K
times log of n where n is the number of
lines and K is the number of
intersections among those lines and I
don't know how to figure that out that's
like a math II thing that you can just
read about I didn't have to figure out
what that complexity was now we saw this
graph before out when the complexity
really matters as numbers get large but
another place where you have to be
careful not to over apply the idea is
when numbers are small so let's zoom
into that lower left-hand corner of this
of the graph if we zoom in there
suddenly the lines don't look so
clear-cut
the green line is actually above the
other lines for most of them and the N
squared line that red line is actually
below everything for a lot of the time
and the reason is that when numbers are
small all those coefficients and lower
order components that we threw away
those mattered right 3n + 1 when n is 1
that one at the end really matters and
also we haven't taken into account what
the actual time of the steps is you
might have an N squared operation where
you are doing N squared times a
millisecond and you might be comparing
that with a constant time algorithm that
always takes a minute well n has to get
pretty large before that constant time
algorithm is worth it when n is a
billion it's worth it but when n is ten
you should stick with the N squared
algorithm so as Rob Pike once said fancy
algorithms are small and it's small and
n is usually small so don't go overboard
with trying to fancy up your algorithmic
complexity
it doesn't matter when n is small and
usually your n is small all right some
advanced topics there's a thing called
amortization which is really a long term
averaging over operations so when I say
that appending to a list is o of 1 that
doesn't mean that every single time you
append to the list it takes a small
amount of time in fact it usually takes
a small amount of time but every once in
a while the whole list has to be copied
and moved someplace else which isn't
which gets longer and longer as the
glist gets longer but it also gets less
and less frequent as the list gets
longer so that over the long run the
average is still o of 1 so amortization
is a fancy word meaning averaging and it
means that individual operations can
take difference amount of times
algorithmic analysis is really about the
long term trends over many many runs and
we haven't talked about the worst case
so earlier we talked about the typical
case and some people think Big O implies
typical case or big fellow implies worst
case no you have to say whether you're
talking about the complexity of the
typical case of the worst case here's an
example where I make a set of 50,000
numbers which differ by 47 I'm kind of
walking up the numbers by 47 adding that
number into the set is an O of 1
operation so the whole building the
whole set is o of n and it took about 10
milliseconds here I'm building another
set of integers exactly the same size
50,000 numbers but I happened to choose
a step that I happen to know was gonna
make all the hashes exactly the same so
all the numbers got exactly the same
hash which turns it into an O of an
operation which means making this set
took 34 seconds 3,300 times longer dicks
also have this problem and people were
using it to ddos web servers which is
why Python added hash randomization and
it's a fascinating topic but it's an
example where although dicks are o of 1
in the typical case occasionally you
have to worry about the worst case and
there's more math so if you dig into the
math basically mathematicians have taken
every letter they either looks like an O
or sounds like an O and giving it a
meaning and you don't need it you don't
need it at all and there might be
mathematicians in the audience right now
who are gonna say you know you're not
really even talking about Big O yeah
shut up I don't care
we all we all this is what we which is
what we mean by Big O and those experts
by the way so I wrote a blog post when I
was first starting to think about this
with the same title they go how code
slows as data grows and a lot of people
liked it but one guy wasn't so pleased
he thought that not only had I gotten
something wrong but the thing I'd gotten
wrong was so important that the entire
blog post was something that I should be
ashamed of and I actually looked into it
I gave him the benefit of the doubt I
learned a little bit more about
algorithmic analysis I concluded he was
actually wrong he remains convinced he
is right the good news is I got another
blog post out of it so if on your
journey to explore these things you find
people like this just walk around them
and keep going it doesn't matter it let
me if you're into the math go and do the
math but if you're just trying to do
software engineering it doesn't matter
alright so in conclusion Big O is useful
it can help you understand how your code
might perform when the data gets very
large it doesn't have to be complicated
it doesn't have to be a fee and you can
do the thing Thanks
[Applause]